life is one of the most fascinating
phenomena in the universe
incredibly elaborate its diverse forms
never fail to capture one's imagination
today we invite you to go slightly back
in time and see the chief milestones in
the earth's biosphere's evolution we
will enjoy the views of the prehistoric
earth find out how and why life came
onto land and take a look at the major
extinction events in the history of our
planet in the second part of the film we
will briefly leave the earth and snoop
around limitless expanses of space in
search of alien life forms
starting out with jupiter's satellites
we will move on to the amazing ocean
world of gliese
1214b after that we will get as far
beyond the solar system as the remote
exoplanet toi 700d
let's get ready for our journey
and begin
[Music]
the first in outer space
actually our earth has been not the
friendliest of places for the greater
part of its existence
let's cast our mind back to the archaean
eon
the earliest time when life was known to
be around
it began four billion years ago and
continued for approximately one and a
half billion years
the early earth had just gone through
the second heavy bombardment
several thousand tons of rocky debris
from the formation of the solar system
was held to the planet smashing the thin
basalt crust that had just formed on the
surface of molten magma even after this
ordeal the young earth cooled off again
and gained its first lithosphere
just a billion years later it became
home to the very first living organisms
the earth of that period had a
comparatively smooth surface
tectonic plates that is rocky bodies
that create high mountain ridges on
collision were simply non-existent at
that early time
there was no diversity in rocks on the
early earth either
banks of wars and rocks were in the
first stages of formation
most of the earth's crust was made up of
the sword a rock formed from magma and
in essence it is solid lava
there was almost no oxygen in the
atmosphere in the archaean
the concentration of nitrogen was
considerably smaller than it is now
the earth was shrouded in a dense
mixture of water vapor and carbon
dioxide with a high percentage of oxides
of sulfur phosphorus and other active
chemical elements the sun was much
dimmer then than it is now
according to some estimates its
luminosity was even 30 percent less than
that of today
that is why our planet was quite a murky
place the moon still used to find itself
in close proximity to it so a day lasted
just around 10 hours
as for tidal waves they reached up from
several dozen to 300 meters
as the earth gradually cooled off water
in the atmosphere condensed and poured
down in torrential rains
at first it accumulated in small bodies
of water in lowlands this water was sour
salty and extremely hot
up to a boiling point in some places
its composition resembled that of
today's geezers
paradoxically this seemingly harsh
environment proved to be the cradle for
primitive life forms that originated and
evolved there
it goes without saying that first
organisms were anaerobic instead of
breathing oxygen as we do which was
non-existent in the atmosphere at the
time first living organisms relied on
other sources of energy
archaean organisms were not yet able to
swim in order to survive they needed a
substrate that is why the biosphere of
the time was a thin slimy film of not
more than a millimeter in width on the
bottom of a sour and hot ocean in its
coastal area
the maximal depth the biosphere reached
down was up to 20 meters as the dense
atmosphere did not allow sun rays to
penetrate deeper
the mouths of underwater volcanoes
offered habitats to bacteria that were
chemotrophs these bacteria didn't need
light and fed on other energy sources
relying on chemical reactions between
sulfur compounds and iron
the earth was cooling off sea levels
rose
the atmosphere became more rarefied and
the sun gradually grew in size
the coastal area favorable for life was
also gradually expanding and by the end
of the archaean eon the biosphere was
confined to a thin stripe along the
coasts and also oases as it were on the
sea bottom near active volcanoes
meanwhile all the land rivers and most
of the open ocean were still completely
devoid of life
if an explorer were to visit the earth
of that period stromatolites would be
the only evidence of life seen with the
naked eye
these sedimentary limestone formations
were created by primordial
microorganisms and may reach up to
several meters in height
there was another problem in that age
the amounts of reagents were
insufficient and that greatly impeded
the evolution of life
evolution hadn't yet produced scavenges
organisms feeding on dead flesh thus
under the influence of gravity and sea
currents
dead creatures accumulated in cavities
on the sea floor
hundreds of millions of years later
these accumulations were processed by
nature into what is now oil fields
around three and a half billion years
ago there are emerged creatures that
were to change the earth beyond
recognition
some bacteria got the hang of
photosynthesis involving oxygen
production
a billion years later on the border
between the archaean and the proterozoic
eons their revolution brought about the
most global extinction in the history of
the planet it is known as the oxygen
catastrophe to name but one term
i've spoken in more detail about it in
an earlier video it is hardly possible
to estimate the scale of that event as
an overwhelming majority of the
creatures didn't get preserved as
fossils practically all the diversity of
anaerobic life-forms that had taken a
billion years to evolve
vanished off the face of the earth
the ancient earth's atmosphere was
exceptionally rich in methane as strong
greenhouse gas
it robustly oxidizes producing carbon
dioxide and water during the process
with methane's concentration in the
atmosphere dropping the temperature on
the planet decreased as well
as a result of this process there
occurred the huronian glaciation
the most large-scale ice age in the
history of the earth which started 2.4
billion years ago and continued for as
long as 300 million years
diggings revealed that in some areas ice
caps reached as far as the equator with
the planet almost totally transformed
into a ball of ice it took the earth one
and a half billion years to go all the
way from boasting boiling lava fields to
endless icy deserts
the proterozoic eon lasted from two and
a half billion years to 440 million
years ago
life persevered in spite of the cold and
evolution although thwarted carried on
nevertheless land remained lifeless
living organisms concentrated in the
coastal area near the equator
and what was happening on the continents
even though they weren't crawling with
life yet land was experiencing something
different and interesting in its own way
alongside the continents banks of metal
ores and new rocks were being formed
in the proterozoic eon areas of dry land
alternately assumed different aspects
and were endless glaciers and stone
deserts at one time or another
it is hard to imagine but just a measly
500 million years ago the greater part
of our planet appeared quite like a
martian desert
luckily for all the dwellers of our
planet
the sun was growing brighter and warmer
eventually the ice gave in
542 million years ago there began the
phanerozoic eon which is the greek for
the eon of visible life
it was peculiar for periods of active
evolution of different species
interlaced with mass extinctions
i have told you about the major ones
but what was the earth like in those
days
at the beginning of the paleozoic era
the greater part of land formed a giant
supercontinent named gondwana
located in the southern hemisphere it
had elaborate terrain and covered over a
hundred million square kilometers
it was comprised of today's africa south
america antarctica australia
the indian peninsula and some other
areas
the smaller continents of the day
lorentia baltica and siberia were
situated near the equator
apart from all that there was a great
number of smaller islands
still up until the silurian period which
started approximately 440
million years ago there weren't any life
forms to speak of on all these expanses
only some simple mosses and lichens were
slowly establishing their dominance on
land it was only at the beginning of the
silurian period that first plants
emerged in tidal areas and near rivers
and only in the tropical zone of that
even in spite of the fact that sea
species and plants became more diverse
marine life forms still concentrated
near the coasts
the area populated incrementally
expanded
just to give you an example the depth of
the ocean at which photosynthesis was
able to take place in the devonian was
just 50 meters which is 10 times as
little as it is now
in the same period which began
420 million years ago and continued
until
358 million years ago the first
decomposers emerged organisms
decomposing dead flesh as a result their
emerged organisms feeding on products of
decomposition
for example alongside scavenging
bacteria there could be found sea
sponges at depths of up to 500 meters
the next period was the carboniferous
period it continued from 358 to
299 million years ago by the time it
began the greater part of the tropical
zone was covered with tree ferns dense
tropical forests did not grow as a mass
there were no organisms back then that
would help wood decompose that is why
bulky trunks of trees didn't trot when
they died and didn't pass any nutrients
to their descendants
they remained lying without decaying and
the phosphorus in their bodies so vital
for plants couldn't be extracted thus
with time lush sapi virgie gave way to
enormous heaps of dead wood covering
enormous stretches of land
later they formed rich deposits of coal
which is still widely used by mankind in
various industries
in areas other than the tropics only
fungi mosses and lichens could be found
they were not able to harden the upper
layer of the earth by their roots and as
a result rain easily washed it off with
rivers turning into muddy streams and
lakes becoming putrid swamps
dry areas became lifeless deserts
it was a time when fishes were
vigorously evolving in the seas and
rivers although life hadn't yet ventured
out into the open ocean
algae hadn't learned to float yet
and so life was still confined to
coastal areas
the carboniferous period was followed by
the permian period
it began
299 and finished
252 million years ago
the first amphibians dared to start
exploring land and plants spread to
conquer subtropics
the sea remained populated only in
shallow waters close to the coasts
the permian period finished with the
most massive extinction event in the
history of multicellular life according
to some estimates up to 96 of marine
species
and 73 percent of land species died out
it is still not known what caused such a
global mortality
the triassic period of the mesozoic era
promptly made up for the lost time
bringing life to a new level during the
process
for the first time in the history of the
earth temperate latitudes could boast
some woods
another revolutionary event took place
on the sea where blue green algae
emerged a type resembling their today's
descendants
it was not vital for them to live in a
substrate anymore and so photosynthetic
microorganisms quickly spread across the
upper layer of the global ocean
tempted by the food fishes mollusks and
darthropods followed it
organic leftovers settled on the sea
bottom thus sea bottom dwellers were
amply supplied with food as well
the global ocean was assuming an aspect
close to today's
the mesozoic era lasted from 250 to 66
million years ago
it is subdivided into three periods the
triassic the jurassic and the cretaceous
this is when dinosaurs thrived
admittedly the most well-known
prehistoric creatures that became
subject of feature and science fiction
movies
the way these ages are depicted we might
get the idea that the earth was covered
with tropical forests from the poles to
the equator
in fact it is completely wrong
indeed forests reached northern
latitudes but only because the average
temperature on the planet was much
higher than it is now
meanwhile equatorial areas on the
contrary suffered droughts
with the forests rapidly spreading
across the entire earth's surface there
were still lots of swamps and deserts
around
the latters were not only scorching hot
and dry as we're used to picturing them
but also moderate cool and even humid
with no herbaceous plants around soils
could not attach themselves to rocky
slopes
only lichens are able to grow on barren
rocks
flowering plants became abundant only by
the middle of the cretaceous period that
is around 100 million years ago
interestingly the first varieties were
trees and by the end of the period there
emerged plants similar to today's herbs
compared to a mighty oak or a giant
sequoia regular grass appears
insignificant
but it is capable of something tree
giants aren't
by mingling their tiny roots in the
ground they help form and strengthen the
turf this not only makes soil tougher
and prevents it from getting washed off
or eroding but also takes care of
getting rid of excess water by letting
it evaporate and accumulating water when
there is a lack of it
on emerging herbaceous plants turned
deserts into steps prairies and savannas
swamps into flood meadows and permafrost
areas into tundra and tundra step
by the time the cretaceous period was
coming to its end the earth had started
to resemble the earth of today it was
lacking just one important touch
mammals
this type of animals had been around for
a long while
but the creatures were not very
widespread until the end of the mesozoic
era
it is still not clear what caused
dinosaurs to become extinct
a giant meteorite global cooling and
other suggestions are listed among the
supposed culprits
either way
these giant saurians vanished thus
vacating a special niche for mammals it
took them 66 million years to evolve
from tiny marsupials into majestic
whales dangerous tigers tough camels and
amusing bats
eventually evolution produced a unique
species
the only living creature capable of not
only adapting to nature but also
changing it
the being that extracts coal formed of
all those dead trees from millions of
years ago to warm up one's dwelling
the creature exterminating other species
for money of a sport
the creature turning vast areas into
wasteland in pursuit of selfish motives
this is homo sapiens
or the human
up until the late proterozoic eon all
life on the earth was to be found only
in oceans
throughout that prehistoric period land
on the surface of the planet would
alternately be covered first by giant
ice caps then by barren lifeless
expanses similar to martian landscapes
and back again
ediacaran the last period in the
proterozoic started approximately
635 million years ago and persisted for
94 million years
the earth of the time was far from being
the most hospitable place
if today's human were to experience the
environment of that period
he or she would very soon pass out due
to asphyxiation
as oxygen concentration in the air was
twice as low back then as it is now
landscapes of the ediacaran period were
endless deserts and rocky mountains
devoid of any signs of life
meanwhile the coastal area of the ocean
was crawling with highly unusual
creatures not even remotely resembling
any of today
they were mainly soft-bodied and
non-motile that is they couldn't move
around and fed of nutritious particles
in water
these organisms supposedly didn't have
either muscles or a developed nervous
system or a hard carapace
with practically no predators around all
these things were by the long the short
of it not yet called for
predators emerged at the very end of the
ediacaran period at once establishing
their dominance in the prehistoric ocean
active hunting proved to be a highly
effective survival strategy
as the soft-bodied non-motile dwellers
of the ocean's bottom unable to either
escape from the enemy or put up a decent
fight or even hide were easy prey
in a way
the ocean was an endless smorgasbord for
first predators full of nutritious food
right there for the taking
it is hardly surprising that most
prehistoric creatures making up the menu
didn't last long
others had to adapt to deal with the new
dangers
[Music]
approximately
542 million years ago there began a
period that was to greatly contribute to
changing what our planet was like
geological layers of that time are
filled with fossils that used to be
highly organized living creatures
these finds give grounds to suppose that
the prehistoric ocean used to be teeming
with creatures sporting an impressive
outer skeleton or carapace
referred to as the cambrian explosion
the process heralded a new breakthrough
in the history of evolution of life on
our planet and the beginning of the
phanerozoic eon or the eon of visible
life
the first period of the phanerozoic eon
is called cambrian
it started
542 million years ago and continued for
about 56 million years
trilobites are the most well-known and
widespread creatures of the time
although these creepy things are not the
only ones the cambrian is notable for
this was the period when the prey
predator system was finally established
it goes without saying that in the
millions of years that followed natural
conditions would interfere with the
established food chains with some
species dying out and others riding high
but the principle stayed
predation became a potent incentive for
evolution which forced organisms to
change in order to be able to deal with
new threats as well as to explore new
areas so far inaccessible to predators
the cambrian explosion produced a great
many completely new forms of
organization of living organisms
many of them didn't prove to be viable
and eventually vanished off the face of
the earth
others on the other hand brought about a
great diversity of new species
for example approximately 550 530
million years ago tiny bottom dwellers
resembling mollusks known as haikulas
developed a sturdy notochord going
through the entire body
these creatures are believed to be some
of the most ancient ancestors of today's
vertebrates
picayas came a bit later
these were not very large creatures
either
they looked like lancelets flatworms or
primitive fish
proud owners of a sturdy and flexible
cord with muscles attached to it they
were able to swim by wriggling their
entire body in a series of s-shaped
movements
this manner of swimming proved to be
quite effective and fast which allowed
early chordates to survive and evolve
into higher organized species
admittedly almost all paleontological
finds dating back to the cambrian are
those of marine dwellers as the
overwhelming majority of the living
organisms of that period lived in the
ocean
some of these creatures we can see in
fossil finds look highly peculiar and
even horrifying
anomalocaris for example was a giant
shrimp measuring up to 60 centimeters in
length
it was also one of the apex predators in
the cambrian period and even though
other finds appear rather bleak in
comparison they are proof of some really
important phenomena
among these the most ancient fossil
finds of land soils can be mentioned
they date back to around 530 million
years ago which corresponds to the
middle and late cambrian without any
specific knowledge in the field one will
fail to see anything special in these
ordinary looking stones
however these prints show that it was
around this time that first primitive
algae and microorganisms started to
venture onto land
later having thrived in their lifetime
they died and decomposed thus forming a
nutritious substrate for their
descendants
first colonies of microorganisms must
have formed in humid and warm places on
land
in shallow waters for example or in the
tidal zone of the ocean with plenty of
water and light and with no animals
around that would be keen on eating them
young algae flourished successfully
adapting to the new conditions
single cell algae was soon joined by
primitive fungi which were not able to
synthesize nutrients on their own but
could feed on what remained of dead
weeds
a hundred million years later the
symbiosis of fungi and single cell algae
produced
lichens
these undemanding things were to become
tip of the spear in exploring great
expanses of new territories
the ordovician period which followed the
cambrian began approximately
485 million years ago and continued for
around 42 million years this is when
marine life was actively evolving
in the ocean mollusks and arthropods
were thriving among the latter's
euripides
many of which dwell to the bottom
to get around more conveniently these
creatures used their jointed limbs
this feature would later be an
indispensable acid and an important
factor in adaptation to life on land
apart from these they revolved jawless
animals similar to today's lampreys and
a bit later their emerged cartilage fish
meanwhile
plants slowly but surely made their way
inland and away from water first
multicellular plants emerged which were
clearly able to survive on land
they left imprints of spores and vessels
that delivered water to the upper parts
of the plants animals on the other hand
still didn't venture out of their
regular environment although it is
probable that some crustaceans did have
a chance to explore coastal areas
this period ended in the ordovician
silurian extinction event its causes are
still not clearly defined yet
but according to the most popular theory
it was brought about by a global ice age
and a fall in the level of the global
ocean that followed
be it as it may
up to 50 of all the species vanished off
the face of the earth as a result of the
extinction
however
life was able to adapt to new conditions
and even take it to a completely new
level next in line was the silurian
period which continued from 444
to 419 million years ago
this was when giant arthropods dominated
the ocean and it is then that one might
come across a euryptorid measuring up to
two and a half meters in length
fishes also thrived among which large
and swift predators over one meter long
come to think of it it is hardly
surprising that some living creatures
preferred to leave the ocean and try to
find other safer areas for their
habitats
and so this is when first arthropods
came on shore
these were prehistoric europeans and
other crustaceans
their tough chitinous carapace protected
them from exposure to the sun and drying
as well as kept their body in shape
their small legs allowed them to move
around on hard surfaces when out of
water
it is reasonable to suppose that first
arthropods that ventured on land made a
point of not getting too far from water
their respiratory organs had to remain
moist in order to function correctly
however the arthropods were greatly
tempted by the abundance of plant food
that was therefore the taking just
beside the sea
the safety factor guaranteed by land was
another attraction as predators hadn't
yet learned to chase their prey if the
latter escaped to land gradually these
explorers fully adapted to the new
conditions and came onto land for good
which later made for an incredible
diversity of species among insects and
spiders as well as other classes of
living creatures approximately 419
million years ago the devonian period
began which was the most important one
in terms of land exploration
it lasted for around 60 million years
this is when rhinophytes spread all over
the planet prehistoric vascular plants
and ancestors of acquisition mosses and
ferns
reaching three metres in height they
densely covered all humid and warm
places of the planet
mainly coastal areas of seas and the
deltas of rivers flowing into them
however neither rhinophytes nor mosses
and lichens that emerged later had a
proper root system instead of a network
of roots that would keep a plant firmly
in place they are just primitive root
stocks at best
that is why soils would quickly get
washed into rivers and turn them into
muddy streams and their deltas into
swamps
in these humid places rich in organic
matter plants were flourishing
giving food to insects and other
inhabitants of the earth of that time
fish in their turn were attracted to
marshy areas by the abundance of insects
and their larvae eventually great
amounts of putrefying organic matter
absorbed oxygen from the water in swamps
which affected the breathing of the
creatures living there
that is why to compensate for the lack
of oxygen fish in those waters learned
to take gulps of atmospheric air
gradually they developed a breathing sac
allowing them to survive outside their
aquatic habitat
simultaneously other appendages were
developing
thick stalks and trunks of plants
growing in marshes offered to fish
reliable shelter from larger predators
however it was hard for them to make
their way through these thickets
thin fins were not adequate for the
purpose
more powerful and muscular limbs were
called for
that is how the fins of fish dwelling in
marshy environments grew longer and
developed additional bones that strong
muscles were attached to these were
first lungfish and in particular
psychopterygi
eustinopterin is a typical
representative of these even though this
strong-finned fish wasn't keen on
settling on land it was already able to
breathe atmospheric air and stay out of
water for certain periods
shallow swamps would often dry out
which is why their inhabitants would
have to migrate to other more humid
places favorable for life
and to do this they naturally had to
move across stretches of land
this is the way acanthus steger got
about it for example
which lived around
365 million years ago in the late
devonian
one of the first known creatures
intermediate between fish and amphibians
acantha steger had gills scales and a
tail fin just like any other fish
at the same time this fascinating
creature sported four legs and a
breathing sack like that of amphibians
that allowed it to breathe atmospheric
air unfortunately acatha stega's limbs
were not strong enough to support its
weight
and its thorax muscles couldn't pump
oxygen for too long
that is why it stayed mostly in water
sometimes crawling from one body of
water to take a dunk in another
gradually the ability of prehistoric
sarcopteryji to breathe atmospheric air
improved their fins grew in power and
turned into fully fledged pores
their appearance underwent great changes
for example tiktaalik a prehistoric
sarcopterygian amphibian fish that lived
at around the same time as acanthostega
had a flat head like that of a frog
being anatomically intermediate between
fish and amphibians tiktaalik had
powerful fins that were able to prop up
its body and move it across solid
surfaces
in addition this amphibian fish could
breathe with both its gills and its
lungs the way its ossicle is designed is
proof of tiktaalik's ability to easily
distinguish sounds both on land and in
water all these signs show that this
creature spent as much time out of water
as in it
in the carboniferous period which
followed the devonian
amphibians came onto land for good
settling in all sorts of ecological
niches in their revolutionary struggle
they developed into such animal classes
as reptiles and synapsids a great
diversity of conditions outside the
ocean stimulated and spurred the
evolutionary process on as land dwellers
are exposed to a much wider range of
temperatures and other factors than
water dwellers
incidentally this question may arise
why did animals come onto land only once
in the entire history of evolution why
didn't a single marine species venture
to live on land in the past
350 million years the answer isn't as
elaborate as it might seem
[Music]
marine creatures are adapted to living
in an aquatic habitat the overwhelming
majority of them are useless and
actually helpless when out of water
to live in another environment they
would need a whole other skeleton
structure as well as outer skin or fur
or shell for that matter and organs of
breathing vision and hearing the
proverbial fish out of water is even
more helpless than a human in the open
sea it is a foregone conclusion that
stranded fish is there for the taking
for any land creature that would care to
have it
when coming onto land in the paleozoic
period
plants arthropods and vertebrates went
on to occupy vacant ecological niches
they didn't have natural enemies in the
new environment while there was plenty
of food around
the chief negative factor in the new
environment was not other creatures but
other conditions fortunately the species
were able to take their time adapting to
them interestingly an example of the
other way around is known to us
prehistoric ancestors of cetacea went
back to living in an aquatic environment
at the same time dominating certain
ecological niches
strange though it may seem on the face
of it there is actually nothing
controversial about it
the fact is that things to adapt to in
the terrestrial environment are tougher
and more diverse
that is why getting back in the water
could be a smart move in order to
survive
whales dolphins and other secondary
aquatic inhabitants of oceans seas and
rivers are living evidence confirming
the fact that evolution is not
irreversible if in certain circumstances
it is better to take a step back
that's what it will do
the evolution of life on earth was
anything but linear
there were periods of higher diversity
as well as periods of almost total
extinction
this was deduced following the analysis
of fossils unearthed at paleontological
digging sites
in the past 540 million years there have
been five major and about 20 minor
extinction events
however the most global crisis of our
planet's biosphere occurred much earlier
approximately 2.1 billion years ago
the first living organisms are posited
to have appeared on earth rather early
approximately but not quite 4 billion
years ago
that is about 400 million years after
the planet's surface had become more or
less suitable for life
even so the earth of that period can't
have looked hospitable
barren rocks dense clouds frequent
storms and earthquakes and an atmosphere
devoid of oxygen made up of mostly
nitrogen methane and carbon dioxide
this was the age of primitive
microorganisms archaea and bacteria most
of which used an oxygenic photosynthesis
that is a kind of photosynthesis where
oxygen is not produced
apart from these creatures it is thought
that there were many forms falling in
between that couldn't be classified as
either living beings or not living
objects with a satisfying degree of
certainty
about 2.7 billion years ago their
emerged oxygenic photosynthesis the kind
of photosynthesis familiar to us where
oxygen is produced this form is still
used by the overwhelming majority of
plants and unicellular algae anaerobic
organisms cannot live in an oxygen-rich
environment that is why ancient algae
used oxygen as a weapon they released it
as a byproduct of their life activity
and this waste killed their competitors
this way algae not only protected their
turf but also spread further to cover
larger areas to dwell on
at first oxygen was spent on oxidation
of rocks in habitats of aerobic
organisms colonies in this manner oxygen
pockets were formed
small areas of oxidized minerals
gradually oxygen went on to spread in
the atmosphere oxidizing methane sulfur
compounds and iron
not able to exist in an environment rich
in oxygen most anaerobic organisms died
out with those of them remaining around
confined to underground pockets where
oxygen didn't reach thus the tables were
turned in the biosphere with the oxygen
breathing organisms becoming the
majority and spreading across larger
areas and the former planet owners
forced to remain in some limited areas
with the spread of the new organisms the
content of gases like methane and carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere dropped
methane oxidized forming water and
eventually carbon dioxide with the
latter taking active part in
photosynthesis
all this reduced the greenhouse effect
and the earth's surface considerably
cooled
the so-called huronian glaciation
started approximately 2.1 billion years
ago and continued for about 300 million
years until the sun's luminosity and
tectonic makeovers had heated up the
earth this was a time when single cell
microorganisms were evolving extremely
slowly constantly thwarted by an
occasional prolonged global ice age the
period has earned a great number of
nicknames like the great oxidation or
oxygenation event oxygen catastrophe and
oxygen crisis to name but a few
even though not really swift this event
was definitely large scale and global
practically all the biodiversity of the
non-oxygen period was eliminated and
evolution was greatly hampered by global
glaciation for a good billion years
however in the aftermath there emerged a
more energy efficient method of
nutrition
approximately
million years ago the phanerozoic eons
started sometimes referred to as the
period of visible life
it was peculiar for vigorous evolution
of multicellular species and in fact it
is actually still in progress
many creatures of that age looked really
bizarre and didn't resemble any of their
today's descendants
suddenly about 450 million years ago
some unknown factor abruptly interfered
with the act of evolution of life forms
the proposed causes include a cosmic
gamma ray burst volcanic activity and
even a large celestial object impact as
it is from 25 to 50 percent of all
living beings became extinct within 7
million years
this series of extinction events dubbed
the ordovician silurian extinction was
hard on trilobites mollusks and some
other marine invertebrates of the time
the late paleozoic era that followed
this extinction event heralded active
evolution of flora on land
the first amphibians and reptiles
emerged in that time too fishes were
actively evolving establishing their
dominance in all fresh water and saline
bodies of water
approximately
372 million years ago the so-called
devonian extinction started
it occurred in several stages that were
alternately followed by comparatively
peaceful periods
peaceful they may have been but even so
the extinction rate of species was
higher than average
the most likely reason for this
extinction is posited to be this
land plants of the time sported long and
powerful roots which enabled them to
extract nutrients from much deeper down
in the soil than before
when waters seeped through soils that
were loosened by plants roots
great amounts of nutrients were washed
into the ocean
as a result algae were positively
thriving there in the abundance of food
and light
the rotting of these algae reduced
oxygen dissolved in the water and the
organisms inhabiting the sea bottom were
simply smothered with nothing to breathe
in the aftermath about 70 percent of the
marine species of that time are
estimated to have died out including
practically all species forming coral
reefs
this triggered global irreversible
changes in the biosphere of the global
ocean
many genera and families vanished
completely and the vacated space was
filled by others
in the carboniferous period which
followed tree ferns exploded in numbers
all over the planet's surface
also there emerged gymnosperm trees and
conifers
it is in this period that rich deposits
of coal were formed which is still
widely used by mankind and various
industries
speaking about the fauna this was the
time when insects thrived that's when
the giant millipede arthropleura was
around which measured two and a half
meters
the mega neura a giant dragonfly with a
wingspan of up to one meter
and the pumina scorpius a scorpion
measuring 70 centimeters
the insects were of these unbelievable
sizes on account of exceptionally high
concentrations of oxygen in the
atmosphere which at that time reached a
staggering 35 percent
the permian triassic extinction event
also informally referred to as the great
dying
occurred about 251 253 million years ago
marking the transition from the permian
to the triassic period
it proved to be the most massive and
global in the entire history of
multicellular life
digging show that up to 95 percent of
marine species and up to 70 percent of
land species vanished from the face of
the earth as a result
interestingly this disaster was rather
swift by geological standards
it took just up to 200 000 years
later it would take not less than 50
million years for biodiversity to
recover for land species and about a
hundred million years for marine species
trilobites a great number of marine and
vertebrates and microorganisms were on
the verge of extinction
insects shrank in size they stopped
looking like horror film creatures on
the loose and instead assumed an
appearance of today's tiny and numerous
creatures the reasons for the permian
triassic extinction event still haven't
been established with certainty
among the proposed hypotheses we may
single out robust volcanic activity as
one of the most likely ones
others worth mentioning are a collision
of our earth with a large celestial
object climate change and active methane
emissions following biological or
tectonic activities
there is no single answer to this
question yet
in the triassic period which followed
the permian triassic extinction event
vertebrates vigorously evolved
this is when archosaurs emerged the
prehistoric saurians crocodiles and
dinosaurs were to evolve from
the triassic period also produced first
mammals although they were not so
widespread at that time
about 200 million years ago the triassic
jurassic extinction event began
sometimes called the end triassic
extinction having lasted for
approximately 10 000 years it marked the
transition from the triassic to the
jurassic period the event claimed about
half of known species on the earth of
that time
they included various reptiles and
amphibians defecated a number of
ecological niches this allowed dinosaurs
to establish their dominance on the
planet and sustain it for the next
and thirty million years
incidentally the reasons for the andreas
extinction event are not known either
and in fact there isn't a single
hypothesis today that would sound
sufficiently convincing
the jurassic and cretaceous periods that
followed the triassic jurassic
extinction event were the times when
dinosaurs thrived and flourished but
these giant saurians were not the sole
inhabitants of our planet at the time
this is when the forefathers of today's
birds flowering plants and corals
evolved as well as small furry
warm-blooded animals
mammals
even though these small creatures didn't
look quite as impressive compared to
tremendous dinosaurs and all their glory
they firmly held their ecological ground
and steadily progressed in their
revolution
mammals got their chance at the end of
the cretaceous period
that is about 66 million years ago what
occurred then was the most well-known
and a rather large-scale mass extinction
event referred to as the cretaceous
tertiary extinction event
according to the first and most popular
hypothesis the extinction was caused by
a giant celestial object impact
everyone would have heard of a meteorite
supposedly killing off all dinos
nevertheless there is no hard evidence
in favor of this version either way the
upshot was that all dinosaurs died out
alongside a great number of conifers
algae and mollusks
the cretaceous tertiary extinction event
heralded the beginning of a new geologic
era the cenozoic which is still in
progress throughout this era mammals
birds and flowering plants have been
actively evolving and spreading across
the earth
mammals settled all over the planet
inhabiting it literally everywhere from
tropical areas to ice caps to the poles
and from the depths of the oceans and
the planet's interior to air currents up
high
eventually evolution produced mankind
even though you would expect people
today to be enlightened enough there are
still those who do not believe in
evolution
however the theory of evolution is not
something to believe in it is a
scientific theory based on facts
the theory of the evolution of species
has come a long way and has undergone
serious revisions since its original
version proposed by charles darwin back
in 1859 still the basic principles of
the theory are the same and to date the
theory of evolution is the only serious
scientific theory that accurately
describes the process of the evolution
of species and the origin of new
creatures
according to some scientists we are now
living in the epoch of the sixth mass
extinction event
they also call it the holocene or
anthropocene extinction
thousands of species have died out in
the past 10 000 years around 900 species
have vanished from the face of the earth
in the past 500 years
today about 40 percent of amphibian
species and 25 percent of mammal species
are under the threat of extinction and
it looks like one of the chief reasons
for this is human activity
will humanity be able to tackle this
threat will life go one step further of
the order as it was always the case
after every major mass extinction event
there is no way of knowing it now
the earth's biosphere boasts a great
potential for recovery and evolution
which by no means implies that it
doesn't need our care
after all
the earth is our only home
for biological life to originate and
start evolving a medley of a great
number of factors is called for
the chief ones are liquid water an
energy source and a certain chemical
diversity
apart from the earth
several more places in the solar system
are potential life-harboring candidates
with mars as the most prospective one
and most closely studied starting from
the recent past
still there are chances of discovering
alien life beyond its orbit too
all it takes is to have a closer look at
the next closest planet to us after mars
if we look away from the sun
[Music]
jupiter is the largest planet in the
solar system
its mass is 318 times that of the earth
this is a gas giant made up mostly of
hydrogen and
helium apart from these methane ammonia
sulfur and nitrogen compounds and water
ice have been detected in its atmosphere
in spite of the diversity of chemical
compounds the possibility of finding
life forms on jupiter itself is
minuscule
what with the absence of any hard
surface high temperatures of the
planet's inner layers and unimaginable
pressure in its interior biological
creatures simply have no chances of
survival
at the same time jupiter boasts quite a
vast array of moons
four of the most well-known ones io
callisto ganymede and europa
were discovered as far back as in 1609
by galileo galilei
quite close to the moon and mercury in
size they're on the list of the largest
satellites in the solar system
it is also suggested that jupiter
accumulated substantial amounts of
thermal energy due to gravitational
contraction when forming
as a result it is now giving off more of
this energy than it is getting from the
sun
that is why the gas giant with all the
objects orbiting it may be seen as a
curious version of the solar system in
miniature
at first glance jupiter's moons may
appear to have no prospects in terms of
searching for extraterrestrial life far
from the sun they are encased in ice and
their atmospheres are not dense
however on closer scrutiny these
celestial objects reveal something
excitingly promising
callisto europa and ganymede are highly
likely to have liquid oceans under the
ice shell
estimates show that space objects with
concealed oceans may offer favorable
conditions for life even if they're much
further from their star than planets
like our earth are from the sun
the thick icy shell on their surface
serves not only as protection against
radiation and meteorite info but also
acts as fairly good thermal isolation
that is why it is feasible that
conditions inside a massive layer of
water may be good enough for life to
originate and evolve there
these assumptions make jupiter's
satellites some of the most attractive
objects for exploration within the solar
system and now let's have a closer look
at each of them
ganymede is the largest and most massive
celestial object in jupiter's environs
of all the satellites in the solar
system it is not only the one sporting
the most impressive dimensions but it
also resembles a real planet more than
any other
ganymede's radius measures
2634 kilometers
which is 8 percent more than that of
mercury
as for its mass it equals 1.48
times 10 to the power of 23 kilograms
this is twice the mass of our moon
interestingly ganymede is the only
satellite in our solar system with a
liquid metal core and its own
magnetosphere
processes of nuclear decay take place in
ganymede's interior this heats the
satellite still more with the average
surface temperature 110 kelvin or
163 degrees celsius below zero the core
on the other hand is estimated to be as
hot as up to 1
500 700 kelvin
investigations of ganymede's magnetic
field carried out by the galileo space
probe showed that there may be a
multi-layer sortie ocean under the
satellite's icy shell as deep down as
200 kilometers or more
the number of layers may reach four
water in each is of different salinity
density and temperature with the layers
separated from each other by some ice
spectrographic investigations of
ganymede's surface show it to have a
rather rarefied oxygen atmosphere this
however isn't an irrefutable proof of
there being biological life on the
satellite
molecular oxygen is likely to form as a
result of the exposure of water ice to
ultraviolet radiation hydrogen the other
product of this chemical reaction
floats away into space
oxygen meanwhile
which is a heavier element settles close
to the surface
apart from large amounts of water ice
other elements found on ganymede's
surface are carbon dioxide sulfur
dioxide
sulfates and some other organic
substances they may well have originated
in the depths of the subsurface ocean
but the mechanisms of their settling on
the satellite's surface are still not
clear
callisto is another celestial object
potentially just as attractive for life
this satellite is jupiter's second
largest one and lies furthest from it
its diameter measures
4820 kilometers almost like that of
mercury callisto is encased in an icy
shell as thick as 80 to 150 kilometers
and it is highly likely that there is a
salty ocean concealed under it
containing large amounts of ammonia and
other substances
the estimates of its depth range from 50
to 300 kilometers and its temperature is
around
251 kelvin or 21 degrees celsius below
zero according to most models
due to impurities and high pressure the
water in the ocean should remain in its
liquid state
below the subsurface ocean there is
bound to be a layer of ice as stickers
around 300 kilometers
and the satellite score made up of water
ice and rocks lies still deeper down
callisto's surface is pockmarked with
craters
spectral analysis of light reflected
from this celestial object revealed not
only water vapor and silicon rocks but
also ammonia carbon dioxide sulfur iron
and magnesium compounds as well as
stolens complex organic polymers
containing nitrogen these brightly
colored substances form on the surfaces
of celestial bodies a result produced by
ultraviolet radiation
callisto happens to lie too far from
jupiter to get more heat from it
besides the tidal influence exerted by
the giant neighbor isn't enough to
deform the satellite although friction
in the process would heat it up
also most of this body is made up of ice
whereas it is preferable that there
should be solid drugs which would
saturate water with elements vital for
life forms to originate
with the diversity of chemical compounds
here rather modest and the temperature
quite low it hardly improves chances of
life evolving here still this
possibility should of course not be
ruled out yet
the most promising of jupiter's
satellites in terms of searching for
alien life is europa
the smallest of jupiter's four galilean
moons it is just a bit smaller than our
moon the equatorial temperature on this
celestial body is 110 kelvin or
163 degrees celsius below zero
at the poles temperatures may drop to 50
kelvin or
223 degrees celsius below zero
europa is tidally locked to jupiter
facing it with the same side only
however its rotation isn't synchronized
ideally there are deviations from the
calculated trajectory
this may mean that there is a liquid
layer between europa's surface and core
this assumption is confirmed by
observation of interaction between the
satellite and jupiter's magnetic field
carried out by the galileo space probe
in the late 20th century apart from that
analysis of crevices europa's surface is
covered with shows that the satellite's
crust moved 80 degrees with respect to
the interior
this would have been impossible without
a liquid layer between them
the massive neighbor exerts a strong
influence over europa by causing
powerful tidal waves in its subsurface
ocean
this way the satellite is heated still
more by internal friction
estimates show that the temperature in
europa's interior is high enough for an
ocean of water to be in liquid state
its depth may reach 100 kilometers and
its volume may be twice that of the
global ocean on our earth
europa is covered with an even layer of
exceptionally smooth and clear ice the
highest elements of relief tower just
several hundred meters above the surface
the thickness of the icy crust may be
anything from 10 to 30 kilometers
although the satellite's surface is
streaked with a whole net of long and
deep cracks some of them may well reach
as deep as the subsurface layer of water
thus the ice at the bottom of these
ravines is valuable material for
studying the inner makeup of europa
another peculiar feature of this moon is
powerful ice-cold vapour geezers
they open up only when europa is at its
furthest point from jupiter with the
height of the spurts reaching as much as
200 kilometers
these giant jets are made up of water
vapor which incidentally is unexpectedly
clean
it is still not known for certain
whether the geysers have anything to do
with the ocean in europa's interior or
they come from gargantuan lakes embedded
in the satellite's icy crust
today the composition of the subsurface
ocean on the satellite is estimated by
analyzing the ice covering the inner
part of its largest craters
only a really large object is capable of
breaking the thick layer of the ice
clean through on impact
after the icy crust is broken the water
in the subsurface ocean at the impact
site freezes and forms the bottom of a
crater
spectral analysis of the craters reveals
magnesium sulfur and iron compounds as
well as hydrogen peroxide and strong
acids
this demonstrates that there is a vast
diversity of minerals in the satellite's
concealed hydrosphere
europa's atmosphere contains oxygen
which forms as a result of ultraviolet
radiation interacting with the ice water
on the surface splitting the water into
oxygen and hydrogen the satellite's
atmosphere however is approximately a
trillion times as rarefied as that of
our earth still according to some
estimates
concentration of oxygen in europa's
subsurface ocean should be sufficient
for supporting single cell aerobic life
forms underwater volcanoes should be
their sources of energy and food
as they saturate water with sulfur and
dine oxides
primitive organisms may attach
themselves to the bottom side of the ice
crust or swim freely in water it was
even assumed that there may dwell
primitive multicellular organisms in
europa's ocean
however this hypothesis appears to be
rather too presumptuous
in fact there is a great many species
on our earth which would be able to
survive in the estimated conditions of
europa's subsurface ocean
there are among them not only bacteria
resistant to harsh environments but
multicellular creatures too
for example tardigrades
consequently we cannot rule out the
possibility of primitive life
originating in the depths of this
celestial object of its own accord
unfortunately enough in spite of the
keen interest we have in jupiter and its
satellites so far they've been
investigated only briefly and that by
spacecraft passing them on our way
elsewhere
no landings on the gas giant's
satellites have so far been attempted at
the moment the largest planet in our
system is being investigated by the juno
probe but as soon as in july 2021 it
will move on to studying the galilean
moons the data collected by juno will
undoubtedly be of great importance and
help get to the bottom of processes
taking place in jupiter's system
as for upcoming missions back in 2012
the european space agency announced
starting work on the juice project or
jupiter icy moon explorer the mission of
the project is to explore in detail the
gas giant itself as well as ganymede
europa and callisto juice will be
launched next year but will reach
jupiter's environs only in 2029
the mission is scheduled until the year
2033. if all goes according to plan our
knowledge about the gas giant and its
satellites will be substantially
expanded
another big research project is nasa's
europa clipper
this automatic probe is planned to lift
off the earth's surface not later than
and to reach jupiter's system in 2032
the probe's objective is quite
predictably europa in contrast to jews
it is this celestial body that clipper
is supposed to focus on more closely
the first steps in theoretical
confirmation of there being ocean worlds
out there that is planets fully covered
in water were made back in the 1970s
that is when evidence was found that
radioactive decay in a planet's interior
and tidal forces may cause water ice to
melt and subsequently form huge oceans
in all likelihood similar processes take
place on jupiter's and saturn's
satellites
however these celestial bodies remain
icebound as they lie too far away from
the sun whose rays would otherwise melt
the thick layers of ice
but when we talk about an ocean planet a
slightly different type of space objects
is meant
the term implies that the ocean on a
planet's surface isn't concealed under a
layer of ice and its depth measures more
than 100 kilometers
theoretical calculations of these
planets formation and evolution
processes were carried out in 2004 by
french astrophysicists headed by
christophe satan
according to this theory if the mass of
a forming planet is more than 10 times
that of the earth this starts to
actively attract hydrogen and helium
from the gas and dust cloud around it in
this manner with time it grows into a
gas giant
by contrast if this planet's mass is
just six to eight earth masses the new
planet is going to be comprised of ice
and rocks roughly in equal measure
just to compare the mass total of all
water in the global ocean on our earth
accounts for just
0.025
of the earth's total mass
in this case provided a space object's
orbit lies far from the host star
this object is going to be either an ice
giant or a cold super earth radioactive
decay taking place inside the core will
help melt some portion of the ice
which in its turn will help form a
subsurface ocean but the planet's outer
layers will still remain frozen
if the planet happens to find itself in
its star's habitable zone its outer
layers will melt and spill all over the
surface in a boundless ocean
theoretical calculations show that a
planet with a mass six to eight times
that of the earth may have a layer of
water over a hundred kilometers thick
the pressure exerted by this amount of
water may reach 20 000 atmospheres
depending on temperature impurities and
other parameters
this is enough for some special exotic
varieties of ice to form like ones
remaining solid even at high
temperatures
in addition unlike the familiar water
ice these modifications would be heavier
than liquid water
for example the density of ice seven
which is likely to form in these
conditions should be around a thousand
six hundred and fifty kilos per cubic
meter
this ice settles on the planet's ocean's
bottom and forms a massive cryosphere
that envelops the more massive core
the opportunity to put these theoretical
assumptions to test arose when a tiny
and dim star was spotted 42 light years
away from the earth
it was dubbed gliese 1214
the diameter of this red dwarf turned
out to be five times smaller than that
of the sun with its mass just 15.7
percent that of the sun
at the same time gliese 1214 is 300
times dimmer than our parent star
while its surface temperature is only 3
000 kelvin or 2
700 degrees celsius
there is nothing particularly remarkable
about the star itself
to be blunt it is just another
non-descript red dwarf that looks like
any of the billions of other stars in
our galaxy
however in 2009 a solitary planet was
detected in its environs which was
dubbed gliese 1214 b
with its diameter measuring two and a
half times that of the earth this
exoplanet is just six and a half times
heavier than our home planet
straightforward calculations show the
freefall acceleration on the exoplanet's
surface to be just 91 percent that of
the earth
the average density of glycer1214b
is approximately
1870 kilos per cubic meter
judging by this comparatively small
value the exoplanet cannot realistically
be made up of mostly metals and rocks as
is the case with our earth for example
but incidentally this average density
value seems to confirm the assumption
that the astronomical body is 75 percent
water or water rice and just 25 tracks
thus it appears safe to suggest that
this exoplanet is an ocean planet
the object lies very close to its host
star the average distance between them
measures just around 2 million
kilometers or 0.014 astronomical units
which is 75 times smaller than that
between the earth and the sun
also the orbit eccentricity is rather
high at 0.27 slightly more than that of
pluto
this means that in its perihelion gliese
1214b is approximately twice as close to
its star than when in its aphelion
as for its orbital period it takes the
planet about 36 hours to complete it
the red dwarf glieser 1214 may be 300
times dimmer than the sun but this
incredible proximity to the star makes
the climate on gliese 1214b scorching
hot
supposing the reflection coefficient of
the surface of gliese 1214b is the same
as that of venus the planet's surface
temperature is supposed to be around
393 kelvin or 120 degrees celsius
if on the other hand the surface is
darker the temperature may reach as much
as 553 kelvin or 280 degrees celsius
due to the fact that the orbit of gliese
1214b crosses the star's disk scientists
are able to carry out spectroscopic
investigations of its atmosphere
still the results are rather ambiguous
if this space object really is an ocean
planet its atmosphere is supposed to
predominantly consist of water vapor
with some accompanying gases
interestingly no lines of hydrogen
helium or complex substances like water
co2 and ammonia have so far been
detected in the planet's spectrum
it is thought that the outer layer of
the dense atmosphere conceals its true
content from the observer
the conditions on the surface of gliese
1214b remind one of what it is like
inside a giant steam boiler
interestingly the atmospheric pressure
in its lowest strata should be at least
15 times as high as that of the earth as
the ocean and the atmosphere are in a
state of thermodynamic equilibrium the
border between them is rather blurred
no wonder as the density of water vapor
just above the ocean's surface is
practically equal to that of constantly
boiling water
as we look deeper at the lowest strata
of the ocean the pressure will continue
to increase until we reach the depth of
a hundred kilometers
with a pressure value of this depth
water will be unable to remain in its
liquid state even at temperatures this
high
and so we will see the bottom made up of
dense and heavy ice whose thickness is
estimated to be upwards of 5000
kilometers
thus most water on the planet is
concentrated here
below the cryosphere there should be the
core made up of rocks and metals
unfortunately chances of life evolving
on any ocean planet are rather thin even
if the surface temperature happens to be
more favorable than on this one
this is so due to the fact that oceans
on planets like that are too poor in
terms of microelements that are vital
for living creatures
even taking into account meteorites that
occasionally bombard the surfaces of
these celestial bodies the chemical
diversity is simply not good enough for
life to originate here
the first exoplanets were discovered
back in the late 1980s
since then the number of detected ones
has increased hundredfold according to
statistics from january 2021
over 4 000 planets in other systems have
already been discovered
apart from these several thousand
candidates likely to be given the status
have been registered
with sufficient evidence from
earth-based observatories most of them
are going to become officially confirmed
exoplanets
the overall number of planets in our
galaxy may supposedly be over one
trillion
from five to twenty percent of these are
close to our earth in terms of their
size and composition
not all of them are in their host star's
goldilocks zones that is not all of them
are habitable
still according to scientific estimates
there are not less than 300 million
potentially habitable planets in the
milky way
exoplanets differ very much in terms of
their environment their dimensions may
be enormous some even beating jupiter
but there are also comparatively smaller
ones close to our earth and size some of
these bodies are hot consumed with
oceans of melt and lava whereas others
are encased in a shell of permanent ice
there are planets out there made
entirely of oceans with not a bit of dry
land on them while in others sulfuric
acid drains or diamond snow are
irregular occurrence
various techniques are used for
discovering other worlds
as a rule it is next to impossible to
spot an exoplanet by simply looking
through a telescope that is why in 2009
kepler was launched the first space
telescope designed for searching for
planets beyond the boundaries of the
solar system
the telescope's cameras had 42
charge-coupled devices or ccds with a
total resolution of around 96 megapixels
with a field of view covering about 25
percent of the sky and coupled with a
one and a half meter mirror of the
telescope it was able to detect
astronomical bodies within three
thousand light years from the earth in
the three and a half years of productive
operations kepler managed to spot over
three and a half thousand exoplanet
candidates the status of over two
thousand of these has already been
confirmed by repeated observations
it was in this period that the smallest
of known exoplanets today was detected
the diameter of kepler 37b is just 35.7
percent that of the earth the telescope
was also instrumental in registering
several stars and brown dwarfs
the transit method was used by kepler in
the search for exoplanets this method is
based on observing the star's luminosity
if the supposed planet passes between
the parent star and the observer this
will be noticed in the telltale decrease
in the star's luminosity the extent of
these fluctuations in luminosity
directly depends on the ratio of the
stars and planets dimensions while their
regularity allows one to estimate the
object's orbital period
the transit method requires accuracy in
measurements changes in a star's
spectrum account for less than two
percent and are usually tenths or even
hundredths of one percent
ripples in the atmosphere dust and
precipitations negatively affect results
produced by earth-based telescopes
that is the reason why telescopes based
on automatic space stations are used for
searching for objects beyond the
boundaries of the solar system
unfortunately in 2013 three and a half
years into the mission the kepler space
telescope had several major equipment
failures
in 2018 the spacecraft ended science
operations completely
kepler was the first spacecraft to be
created specifically for looking for
exoplanets
however most of the objects that managed
to spot happen to be too remote and dim
to study them in any satisfying detail
that is why the next space research
complex had slightly different
parameters
kepler was succeeded by the test
telescope launched by nasa on the 18th
of april 2018.
its main object was searching for rocky
exoplanets orbiting the brightest stars
within 200 light years from the sun
this telescope also used the transit
method and here is the spacecraft's
brief profile tess is equipped with four
refractors with a 24 by 24 degree field
of view and a 10 centimeter aperture
the spacecraft's peculiar orbit allows
it to cover both the northern and the
southern parts of the sky which is
approximately 85 percent of the entire
sky
photos are taken by four cameras and the
resolution of each camera's ccd is 16.8
megapixels
toi 700d is one of the most notable
objects discovered by tess
this exoplanet became the first object
of the kind comparable to the earth and
size and which found itself in the
habitable zone of its star
it orbits toi 700 a red dwarf lying
slightly over a hundred light years away
from the sun
it is a small and rather cold star its
temperature is half that of the sun and
its mass and radius are just 40 percent
those of the sun
toi 700 is peculiar for its high
stability
not a single flare has been registered
on it since the beginning of
observations
a star's stability is a positive feature
because bursts of activity are able to
divest its planets of their atmospheres
and be generally pernicious for
potential life on planet surfaces
there are at least three planets
orbiting toi 700 the one closest to it
toi 700b
is comparable to the earth in size
its mass is approximately 1.07 times
that of our planet and its radius
differs from that of the earth by not
more than two percent
unfortunately toi 700b is too close to
its host star
it is within about .06 astronomical
units and a year on the planet lasts
just 10 days
in addition to that chances are it is
tidally locked that is it faces the star
with one in the same side
this means that the planet is likely to
be scorching hot the planet lying
further from its star toi 700c
is thought to be a mini neptune
its mass may be from 5 to 13 times that
of our earth and its radius is 2 or 3
times that of the earth
it takes toi 700c 16 days to complete
one orbit around its host's star
located closer to the star than the
inner border of the habitable zone it
must be too hot for life to originate
and evolve there
toi 700d is the third and at this point
the remotest planet in the system
discovered by now it takes 37.4 days to
complete a full orbit which by the way
lies along the inner edge of the
habitable zone
the mass of toi 700d hasn't been gauged
precisely and may be anything from one
to three times that of the earth
at the same time the planet's radius is
just 20 to 30 percent bigger than that
of the earth
toi 700d is thought to be a rocky world
but its exact composition is not yet
known
the amount of energy received by the
planet from its star is 86
that of the amount we receive from the
sun
assuming the planet's atmosphere is
similar to ours the steady state
temperature on the surface of toi 700d
is estimated at
268.8 kelvin or 4.3 degrees celsius
below zero
however due to the greenhouse effect or
other features of the atmosphere we may
not know yet this figure may shift
either up or down
there is no precise data on the
eccentricity of toi 700d
but it is thought to be small at around
point eleven as the planet's orbit finds
itself at the inner edge of the
goldilocks zone the planet's
eccentricity however small may
incidentally turn out to be perceptible
when the planet comes too close to its
star from time to time thus actually
leaving the habitable zone
still with a year on the planet lasting
slightly over one earth month such
unfavorable periods are expected to be
rather short
if there are living creatures on toi
700d
then they might be able to weather the
harsh spells in a state of anabiosis
alternatively they could adapt or
migrate to less inclement areas
even though the data acquired by
spectral analysis of toi 700d can't be
enough for making conclusions there is a
chance that there is liquid water on the
planet's surface
then there is bound to be the greenhouse
effect too
which will help the surface temperature
to reach favorable values
as i've already mentioned toi 700d along
with the other known planets in the
system is highly likely to be tidally
locked to its star
if this is the case there should be a
stark difference in temperatures between
the sunny side and the shadow side
this contrast could be leveled off by
dance atmosphere but that would cause
powerful hurricane winds
although the main mission of tess has
been accomplished by now it still has
enough resources to carry on operations
the telescope will continue taking
snapshots of the sky including the milky
way plane which is the most challenging
direction for observation
over 2
100 exoplanet candidates have been
discovered by tess in the course of the
main mission
not less than 66 of them have already
been confirmed
apart from that
six supernovae flares have been
registered three exo comets identified
and a great number of photos taken of
small bodies in the solar system the
latters were not objects of the main
mission but are of course of scientific
interest
toi 700d is still guarding its mysteries
and waiting for its explorers
great hopes are placed on the new
orbital telescope james webb which may
help investigate this world and a number
of other ones
the new telescope is supposed to provide
images of not only exoplanets lying
closest but also detect their moons
and carry out spectral analysis of their
surfaces the launch of the telescope is
planned for the 31st of october 2021.
if all goes according to plan first data
will be available as soon as next year
will we ever discover a world that could
rightfully be called the second earth
and if we do
will we be able to reach it
distances in space are just too much for
humans
could it be that we're confined to the
limits of our system forever
allowed only to gaze at the vast
infinite universe
[Music]
it goes without saying that we've only
briefly touched upon the question of
what life is as well as its meaning in
the universe
this topic is truly inexhaustible
even though mankind has accumulated
impressive amounts of information about
the world around us there are by all
accounts a lot of blank spots in our
knowledge
still every new day yields a fresh load
of data about the universe and our role
in it is the genesis of life something
that was to be expected or did it all
start by a lucky chance
is space actually crawling with life
with us none the wiser or are we alone
in the universe
these exciting questions still remain to
be answered
[Music]
[Applause]
you